Donald Trump isn't exactly known for
thinking in foreign policy details my
foreign policy will always put the
interests of the American people and
American security above all s but
recently Trump got specific about
something important NATO the North
Atlantic Treaty Organization and what he
said shocked everyone NATO is a military
alliance between the US Canada and a
large chunk of Europe
it began in 1949 as a means of deterring
Soviet attack on Western Europe in
Washington the United States break2 170
year old tradition as it joined 11
nations in the tightening of the
Atlantic defense treaty basically saying
if you attack one of us you'll get a
response from all of us NATO was grown
sense to include 28 countries including
former members of the Soviet Union
intervened to end the Bosnian war in
1995 and respond to the 9/11 attacks the
decade-long mission in Afghanistan the
Alliance has helped keep the peace in
the northern hemisphere for more than
half a century and now Donald Trump is
threatening to destroy the whole thing
so Trump is in an interview with New
York Times in July 20th sänger asks him
can the members of NATO including the
new members in the Baltics count on the
United States to come to their military
aid if they were attacked by Russia
Trump replies have they fulfilled their
obligation to us if they fulfill their
obligations to us the answer is yes and
if not then Trump says I'm not saying if
not Trump is probably referring to the
fact that all NATO countries have agreed
to spend 2 percent of their GDP on
national defense as part of the treaty
the u.s. is just one of five countries
that met that benchmark in 2016 and
Trump isn't the first to call out
countries that happen the majority of
allies are still not hitting that 2%
mark everybody's got to step up and
everybody's got to do better but Trump
is the first and only one to suggest
that our commitment to NATO should be
contingent on those spending levels and
even his fellow Republicans are calling
him out now I have friends that you know
serve in Parliament in places like
Estonia that every day worry about the
Russians deciding that this is the time
to reenacts and to take them back and
comments like this are not only
ill-informed they're dangerous I mean
it's the most successful
pterri alliance in the history of the
world i want to reassure our NATO allies
that would any it should any of them be
attacked we'll be there to defend them
and I'm willing to kind of chalk that up
there rookie mistake the Trump isn't
backing down if Mitch McConnell says
that and he's wrong so all I'm saying is
they have to pay so why is this such a
big deal because of the way that NATO
works you see NATO deters attacks
there's something called credible
commitment there's no organization that
can force the United States to go fight
for Estonia or Latvia or Lithuania a
country like Russia has to believe that
the United States is willing to
intervene even if it risks World War
three that's why political leaders of
both parties haven't we've earned from
the commitment to defend the NATO
alliance until now and he used the NATO
alliance almost as a transactional
business alliance so that is a complete
break with American policy and Trump's
comments come at a time when NATO is
particularly relevant Russia invaded
Ukraine in 2014 even annexing part of
the country this came just about six
years after its invasion of Georgia
that's why the New York Times asked him
specifically about the Baltic States
Soniya Latvia and Lithuania Russia is
getting increasingly aggressive on its
borders and if it seems like the United
States is wavering Putin might be more
tempted to attack one of the Baltic
states as part of a plot to destroy NATO
and the Republican presidential
candidate has just invited him to try